okay welcome back everyone welcome to
the second lecture
of cs229 machine learning
so where were we so uh
in lecture one we we were going through
uh
some of the review material linear
algebra
uh and today for the uh for today the
plan is to finish up the review of
linear algebra some of the topics we
could not
cover on monday review some matrix
calculus
or multivariable calculus and then also
review some probability theory
with that we will be finishing all the
review and from the next class
we're going to start with actual machine
learning uh with linear regression
okay so uh a quick recap
so
so we went over what a vector is
and the matrix is
right and uh we saw some of the
some of the applications of linear
algebra we saw why we need to
um study linear algebra for example
to represent your data
covariance matrices
right kernels
you're not expected to know what a
kernel is at the stage but you know this
just to um
name a few concepts that we'll be using
later and and also
in general multivariate calculus
right and then we went over some
operations
such as a vector vector operation
like the inner product or the dot
product
the outer product so the inner product
we take two matrices of the same
dimension for an outer product they need
not be the same
and then we also um went over some
operations such as
matrix vector product um where we saw
two interpretations
the dot product interpretation and the
scaling interpretation yes questions
is that better awesome thank you
we saw the matrix uh vector um operation
um the both the dot product view and and
the scaling of the columns
uh interpretation and then uh we also
covered
matrix matrix multiplication
and we saw a couple of interpretations
of that the the inner product
interpretation and the outer product
interpretation
and then
we reinterpreted matrices as
functions or operators rather than
thinking of matrices as a grid of
numbers
now think of them as an operator where
they operate
on a vector that you are multiplying
with the think of the vector that you
are multiplying a matrix with as the
input and the vector that you get as the
output
right and with that function
point of view ah
function interpretation of matrices
right with this function point of view
we saw
some geometrical interpretations of the
subspaces
which is closely related to
the rank and the inverse rank
inverse and we also covered
projections right
so projecting a a vector onto a subspace
essentially means finding the point
on the subspace that is nearest to the
vector that we are trying to project
right projections and we saw the
uh the projection matrix so if you're
trying to project a vector v
on to the columns of x
of x where x is a matrix and v is a
vector then the projection matrix
is essentially x x transpose
of sorry x
x transpose x inverse
x transpose right this is a matrix so
x is a matrix x transpose is a matrix x
transpose x is a matrix
it's inverse as a matrix you multiply
this matrix from
x itself from the left and x transpose
from the right you get one
you know you still get a matrix so this
matrix is the projection matrix
and any vector you you multiply it with
right you multiply this matrix with a
vector
you get a new vector called u
and u will be the projection of v onto
the subspace
spanned by the columns of x right
this is an important concept that we'll
come back
when we talk about linear regression
right so that's the
projection and we also started talking
about
vectors
eigen vectors and eigen values
right so that is where we left off
eigenvectors and eigen values are those
special vectors for square matrices
where the operation of the matrix
on the vector does not change the angle
it only rescales it by some amount
and the eigenvalue is the ratio by which
the vector gets scaled along those
specific directions so each eigenvector
comes with a corresponding eigenvalue
the remaining vectors which are not
eigenvectors are not eigenvectors in the
sense they can
change their direction is there a
question
so uh questions so the question is do
the columns of
x span the subspace uh u so
um to clarify x the columns of
x define the subspace onto which we want
to project
any given vector right so x the v
v over here is some any given vector and
we want to project it on to
the the subspace band by the columns of
x ah
by taking x we construct this matrix you
know
x transpose x inverted you know multiply
from the left by x
from the right by x transpose you get
another matrix
now take any vector v and
multiply v by this matrix right and you
get
an output vector u now that u will be
in the subspace spanned by the columns
of x
and it will be the nearest point to v
such that
it you know it's it's
it's in the subspace and also nearest to
v
thank you thanks for asking the question
yes question
um
uh i'm not sure i followed your question
completely
did you mean you want to add multiple
you want to consider
different vectors that you want to
project on to the subscription
okay so which is different from this v
okay so
let's call them x 1 x 2 x 3 okay
so the question is um if if i want to
project v
on to the subspace spanned by the
columns of x
would it be different from what we would
get
if we were to project v on to first
column of x
separately to the second column of x
separately to the third column of the
x and then sum those projections uh the
answer is no they will not be the same
uh just because um here's an example
um consider this to be
x x1 um call it x1 so this is like the
first column of x
and let this be the second column of x
x 2. now suppose there is a vector v
and let me the vector should ideally be
out of the subspace so imagine there's a
a vector over here right and now i want
to project this on to the subspace of
x right now if i were to separately
project it to say
x2 first this might be uh the projection
separately to x1 first this might be the
projection and i sum them up
it's going to be something here but from
here the nearest projection is
is is this
right if you project them separately and
add them up you don't necessarily reach
the nearest point
does that does that make sense yes
question
yes if if if they are if they are the uh
uh
orthonormal to each other
maybe but but x1 and x1 need not be
orthonormal there they could be any
anywhere any vectors
i'm not sure about the orthonormal i
need to think about that but in general
you know it doesn't hold that you can
project them separately
any more questions
all right okay so moving on
so uh next we're going to focus more on
eigenvalues
and and see some of some of its
properties so um
okay so here's the the picture that we
started with
um so imagine
an input space in r3
and this is your input space
right and so this is your
x axis y axis z axis
right and ah the picture that we
that we kind of uh started with to to
build our intuitions was to
consider uh a unit ball like a soccer
ball that's centered around the origin
of of radius one right and
you have the matrix your your square
symmetric matrix a
which is also in r 3
and symmetric
right and take this
shape and run it through a now what does
that mean what does it mean to
i mean we know how how we can take a
vector and run it through a and get an
output vector but what does it mean to
take a shape and run it through a and
get another shape
it just means take every point on the
surface separately run it through a
and reconstruct the resulting shape on
the other side right so
um so this is our input
take every point on the surface so this
is a three dimensional ball you know i'm
just writing to the circle you know it
has
it's a three dimensional armor and run
it through a
and we get an ellipsoid
right now ah
at this point we are still still talking
about symmetric uh
square matrices now the ah
the principal axes of this
ellipse are the eigen vectors of a
right so um the the the longest axis is
going to be the eigen
eigen vector corresponding to the
largest eigen value um and that's
because
points along these axis on on
on the input sphere will
get mapped to a point along the same
direction but at a different
different distance from the origin right
and the ratio of
the output distance from the origin to
the input distance to the origin is the
eigen value corresponding to that eigen
vector
right now the product
of all the eigen values of a matrix
is also the
determinant right so ah the determinant
of a matrix
is the
product of all
eigen values
right so the determinant of a matrix
depends only on the eigenvalues
right the eigenvectors don't matter if
you have another matrix which
which results in a shape that is similar
to
this ellipsoid it will have the same
determinant even though it may be
oriented differently
right so the determinant is the product
of all the eigen values
and another thing that kind of ah
becomes obvious here is
the product of all the eigen values over
here is basically the ratio of
the the the principle you know of
of distance to this distance there's one
eigen value the ratio of
this distance this distance is another
eigen value and so on
and it so happens that the product of
all the
lengths of
these half diameters
of of the different axes of an ellipsoid
is also the volume of the ellipsoid
right so another interpretation of the
determinant is
it is the volume
of output shape
over volume of input shape
for any shape for any shape that has you
know some non-zero volume on the input
it need not be just a sphere it could be
you know a cube it could be any
arbitrary shape it has some volume
run that shape through the matrix a you
get an output shape
right and that output shape has some
volume as well
now the ratio of the output volume to
the input volume is the determinant of
the matrix
now it should be obvious that if the
rank of the matrix is
is if it's not a full rank matrix it
means one of the eigen values is zero
which means this sphere would have
collapsed into an ellipse rather than
retaining its ellipsoid shape and the
volume of an ellipse in a three
dimensional space is
zero exactly right so um what you will
see is that the
volume of the output shape will be
for non-full rank matrices
right the volume of the output shape
will be zero over
you know some non-zero and again you
know um
this is also you know directly clear
because it's the product of on
eigenvalues one of the eigenvalues is
zero so you know
the volume of the output shift will also
be zero
any questions about this now the reason
why
we focus on this this volume
interpretation
is because this is going to help us
further down in the course
right especially when we are are
talking about talking about
operations that we perform on random
variables
right this concept of determinant will
become
very important because even though we
perform some kind of a linear operation
on a random variable
we will then need to adjust the
resulting uh
random variables probability by dividing
it by the determinant so that
the volume of the the uh of the pdf
should still integrate to one so you
know to maintain
constant volume as you perform
linear operation you you will you will
need to divide the data you know divide
the output by the determinant to
to maintain the the volume
um but if if you don't you know that's
that's you know advanced we're going to
go over that again
in in a lot more detail uh for later in
the course but
it's it's important to kind of have this
this ah
this understanding of the determinant
that it is it is uh the determinant kind
of tells you how much
the the matrix either expands or
contracts
the space right if if the volume the
resulting volume is is bigger it's kind
of
expanding and if it's if it's if it's
smaller then it's kind of
contracting contracting the input space
right
which also means that you know if one of
the one of the
eigen values is zero it means the
determinant is zero
and therefore the matrix does not have
an inverse
right now that's that's you know that
should also be kind of obvious because
you take
you take a soccer ball um you if you if
you kind of
transform it into an ellipsoid you can
still map it you know one
map every point on the ellipsoid back to
the soccer ball but if you if you kind
of squash it into an ellipse then you
know
uh there's no way you can map back a
two-dimensional space back into a
three-dimensional space right so there's
no there's no
inverse if any one of the eigen values
is zero
okay that's about determinants any any
questions about determinants
okay i'll take that as a no next
moving on
there is a technical term for the
collection of all
eigen values of a matrix and that is
called
anybody respectful yeah so
yeah yeah yeah um they're they're all
pretty related so the spectrum is uh
collection of
eigen values of a matrix and you know
you generally
sort them in descending order you write
the the largest eigenvalue first and
kind of
sort them in the in the um
in the uh descending order now
for most operations the spectrum of a
matrix pretty much
contains all the information that we
care about
uh about you know the matrix for for
most of the operations essentially uh
you know it tells you what is going to
be the resulting
shape of of uh the ellipsoid uh
for for a given uh input unit bar
the orientation may be different but you
know you can kind of adjust that by
doing a change of basis you know
to orient things differently but
essentially the the
core of the operation of what a matrix
does is kind of captured by
the spectrum or you know the collection
of eigen values
and there is this theorem called the
spectral theorem
which we are not going to prove
the spectral theorem which says for
every square matrix
or say d by d every square matrix
that is also symmetric
right has
real valued eigen values
and orthonormal eigen vectors
right ah which which makes you know um
and this actually covers a whole lot of
different different
matrices that we are interested in for
example hessians
are square matrices and they are
symmetric right which means they have
real valued eigenvalues all their
eigenvalues are
real some could be zero some could be
negative but they're all real valued
there are no complex eigen values what
that's what it means and and and has you
know orthonormal eigen vectors
hessians covariance matrices
right kernel matrices
again we're going to see what kernels
are later but you know just so that you
you know why this is kind of uh relevant
for the course
right all these have
they are all square they are symmetric
and therefore they have real valued
eigen values and
orthonormal eigen vectors
with this next we are going to start
something called
the quadratic form
quadratic forms and and and this is
closely connected to ah
um you know definitiveness you know
positive semi definite negative semi
definite
ah and that's going to pop out of this
so what's a quadratic form
given a matrix a assume it is a square
right and you have some vector x
r d the quadratic form
is also written as x transpose
a x
right so far we've seen ax
but x transpose ax is is also called the
quadratic form
and the the
quadratic form holds for any
square matrix but in general we assume
whenever we are working with a quadratic
form
we just assume that a is symmetric as
well
and that's because for any
quadratic form expression a where a is
may or may not be symmetric
that always exists another b
such that x transpose b x equals x
transpose ax
where b is symmetric
it's pretty easy to show you know why
this is the case
it's it's it's also in the notes i don't
want to spend too much time on proving
this it's a very simple proof
but in general whenever you're dealing
with quadratic forms it is safe to
assume
that the matrix is is
symmetric just because you can always
represent it as
another symmetric matrix b where x
transpose b
x equals x transpose x for all values of
x
okay and ah and b actually happens to be
just
half of a plus half of
a transpose it's it's a you know a
pretty simple proof
yes question
what's the equation x transpose bx
oh it just shows that for every for any
matrix square matrix
a there is a corresponding
square matrix b which is also symmetric
which by the way is calculated like this
such that x transpose ax equals x
transpose b x for all x
which is why you can just assume that a
is symmetric
uh because even if it's not symmetric
you can use the corresponding b in its
place
because their values are the same at all
values of x
right now this quadratic form
is used to oh
i just didn't want that to be
distracting right
so we use the definition or the the
quadratic form
to define what is also called as
definitiveness
right so ah
the way we define definitiveness is uh
if x transpose a x
you know for a matrix uh a square
symmetric matrix a
and any value x um is
greater than 0 you know for
all x so this symbol means for all x
then we call the matrix a we say a
is positive definite
right similarly if x transpose a x is
greater than equal to 0
for all x
here for all x naught equal to 0 not
equal to 0 because when x is 0
you know a transpose x x transpose ax
will be zero
then a is
positive semi-definite
right if it is less than zero
for all x ah not equal to zero then a
is negative definite
if it is less than equal to 0 for all x
not equal to 0
and a is negative semi definite
right and if you cannot say ah
any statement about this where for some
values of x it is greater than 0 some
values of x it is less than 0
then we say it's just indefinite
right so this is this is the definition
of what is a positive semi-definite
matrix or a positive definite matrix
which means
take the square matrix a you know you
can assume it to be symmetric
um and for any value of
x for any vector x calculate x transpose
ax
right if all the the resulting values
of x transpose a x for every x that is
not equal to 0 if it is greater than 0
then
a is positive positive definite if it's
greater than n equals zero it's positive
semi definite
and so on right
now let's
let's try to kind of ah understand this
geometrically what
what does this actually mean why is this
you know
what what's what's what's kind of what's
the meaning of x transpose ax
because you know we seem to care about
it its value so much
now first recall let's go back to the
dot product a transpose b
where a and b are any two vectors right
let's let let um this be a
this be b right ah
if the value of a transpose b or if the
angle between a and b
is less than 90 degrees then
a transpose b will be
positive right
if a and b are
then a transpose b is zero
and the other one is obvious
if it's more than 90 degrees then a
transpose b is less than
zero
right now um
this is for any two given matrices a and
b now what the quadratic form
we see over there you know quadratic
form but what
what is actually doing is it instead of
looking at ah a
and b is looking at x transpose with
a x you are seeing what happens to x
and you know and then you run it through
a you get ax
right it's it's doing a dot product
between the input and the output of a
for any given ah value of x right that's
that's essentially what
the quadratic form is doing and it is
um and we saw in the picture previously
before let me try it again
this time i'll just write in two
dimensions so assume this is the
the the unit sphere and
this is the ellipsoid that you get due
to a
it's just r2 so this is the input input
shape the input ball that we are going
to run through and just the output that
you're going to get
and what what this is
essentially saying is that for a
positive
semi-definite matrix or a positive
definite matrix
for
any value of x on the input that we take
run it through a we get a corresponding
output
right now the angle between these two
is less than 90 degrees
right does that make sense x transpose
ax is greater than zero
so x is this here was
input x and this was output ax
right as long as their angle is less
than 90 degrees it will always be
greater than 0 right and
this is again this is how we relate
extra
the the the definitiveness statement to
eigenvectors eigenvalues
because if you have a matrix that has
all positive eigenvalues
then the eigenvectors only scale gets
scaled
in a positive direction right
and this eigenvector gets scaled
you know in a positive direction and x
transpose a
x for eigen vectors are always positive
because they're just
scaled in a positive direction and and
when you when you do a dot product
between two vectors
which are oriented similarly it's always
positive right
so you kind of think of the eigen eigen
vectors
as acting as pivots
and anything inside them get mapped to
vectors that are also in the same
quadrant
right if one of the eigen values was
negative so for example
if this eigen value was positive but
this eigen value was negative
then a vector over here
could have gotten mapped to you know to
something in this quadrant which means
its angle could have been bigger than ah
90 degrees
which means x transpose x could have
been negative
right if you have all positive eigen
values
then the eigenvectors kind of act as
pivots where
the vectors inside one quadrant remain
in the same quadrant in the output space
right so how does that connect to the
definition of positive definite positive
definiteness
so for a positive
definite matrix
all eigen values
are greater than 0 right
for a positive semi definite matrix
they're all
greater than equal to 0 for a negative
definite matrix
all the eigen values are less than 0 and
for a
negative semi-definite matrix they are
less than equal to 0 and for an
indefinite matrix they can be you know
greater than or less than zero
right so the the the uh
the definitiveness of a matrix which is
defined
by the quadratic form has a
one-to-one relation with the spectrum of
the matrix
any questions about that
yes
yeah so um when i say it is less than or
greater than
equal to zero for a few x's it's going
to be greater than zero for a few other
x's it's going to be less than zero
so if you construct any positive uh
definite matrix
where any symmetric matrix where one of
the eigenvalues is positive and one of
the eigenvalues negative
you're going to get a matrix and they're
going to be you know you know
um eigenvectors corresponding to
the ah they're going to be vectors
corresponding to the eigenvectors of
that matrix which will result in
you know the value the quadratic form
being greater than 0 or less than zero
right any questions on this
ok so next we are going to move on to um
decomposing matrices
so given a matrix there are many ways to
decompose it and what do we mean by
decomposite
decomposition we are going to look at it
right away
the two decompositions that we are going
to
that we are going to look at today are
the singular value decomposition
or it's also called the svd
and the eigenvalue decomposition
those are the two things we are going to
go over today
because these are you know these two are
are um
probably the most um interesting ones
from a theoretical point of view
there's another you know decomposition
that's used
very uh uh frequently called the
cellulosky decomposition
maybe we'll i'll just mention in passing
what what
that is but the interesting ones to
analyze are the singular value
decomposition and the eigenvalue
decomposition right the singular value
decomposition
um
so this is s v d
this one i am going to call it
eigen value decomposition right
so ah matrix a
for singular ah value decomposition can
be
any matrix a right it can be any matrix
whatsoever
right but for eigen value decomposition
you need square matrices
thats thats ah one main difference and
the decomposition itself is defined like
this
right so singular value decomposition is
generally
you say a equals
u s
v transpose and eigen value
decomposition
we generally say a equals
u d u inverse
what does what what what are we saying
here basically basically what we are
saying is
given a matrix a so let's let's again
think of this
in terms of functions right matrices you
know think of matrices as functions
that's that's always
a useful approach what this is basically
saying
is ax
can also be written as
u s
v transpose x which means
first multiply
x with v transpose and you get some
output
vector then take that vector as input to
s
and you get some output and take the
output of multiplying by s and feed it
as it pushes to u
and you get some output and what it's
basically saying is
the operation performed by x can be
decomposed into three sub
matrices which you apply like a pipeline
you know first apply
v transpose to x each of these is
a matrix first you apply v transpose to
x you get
you know a different vector you take
that vector
you know feed it as input s you take the
output of that feed it as input to u
you know it's just a nested operation
right
and and similarly um the eigen
decomposition of
of ah a can be written as
right we saw what a matrix a
ah essentially essentially does right so
so what the singular value decomposition
and eigen value decomposition are saying
is that you can decompose a matrix
a into three submatrices such that
the operation performed by a on
any vector x can be split into three
subparts
right
so the operations
so before we move on to operations let's
talk a little more about these
individual matrices so u and v
are
they are orthonormal matrices
and s is also called
a singular the the set of singular
values it's called
and this is a diagonal matrices diagonal
matrix
where the singular values are along the
diagonal of
of s and d is also diagonal
and the eigen values are along the
diagonal
of t so the eigenvalue decomposition
decomposes into
u d u transpose where the columns of u
are the eigenvectors and d is the set of
eigen values
and u would for example
if this is u and
this is d then there is a one to one
mapping between
the eigen vector and the corresponding
eigen value
and a different eigen vector
and the corresponding eigen value and so
on right
the action performed by a is completely
defined by
its set of eigen vectors and eigen
values
for a square matrix a and for
any matrix a you have ah
you have a collection of singular values
in place of eigen values
and you have a u
and another matrix v transpose
for the singular value decomposition u
and v
are you know uh they are they're
different matrices in general
they are um they just need to be
orthonormal which means their unit
length and all of them are
orthogonal to each other whereas for
the the eigen value decomposition the
the third matrix has to be the inverse
of
of the of u itself so this
is just u inverse
right now ah
we have uh so we can we can we can uh
break down the eigenval the any matrix
ah into the singular value decomposition
but the cool thing about the uh the
singular value decomposition is that you
are guaranteed
that the singular values of the matrix
are going to be real valued
right no matter you know what matrix a
you
you feed in it need not be full rank it
could be
anything whatsoever any real valued
matrix you know as long as you know the
values in the in the grids are all real
valued
you can always come up with a
decomposition of this form
where the where the
u and v matrices are orthonormal and the
singular values are all
real yes question okay no question
now ah however with eigen value
decomposition
things are a little different in that it
is limited to square matrices only
yes question
so the question is aren't isn't the
eigenvalue decomposition
diagonalizable
so if you
by diagonal diagonalizable if you mean
diagonalizable into
real valued eigen eigen
values then yes but in general you can
take any square matrix
and the eigenvector the eigenvalues may
be complex but you can still
break down
so um if it's not uh diagonalizable then
this is they're going to be complex
values in there
but if you're okay with with complex
numbers then you can always represent it
like this
right so um
yes
so our s and d diagonal matrices with
eigenvalues so in the eigenvalue
decomposition
it is the d matrix is diagonal with
eigenvalues
in the singular value decomposition the
the s is a diagonal matrix with what's
called as singular values
not the eigenvalues eigenvalues are only
defined for square matrices
so this is just the way you can you can
break down a matrix into
into ah into sub components right
now it is kind of interesting to see
you know how these are related let us
call this
a um svd
so i'm going to call this step one
step two and step three
right where step one corresponds to what
happens when you take the first piece
and and look at its action on x
step two is take the output of step one
and run it through the next matrix and
step three is take the output of step
two and run it through the third matrix
right now u and v
or u and u inverse are all orthonormal
right which means step one for both
singular value and and eigenvalue
decomposition
is um here it is it is v
transpose and here it is u inverse
and the action is going to be just
rotation
and mirroring
right rotation
and possibly mirroring
in fact it's actually going to be just
just a rotation it's not even going to
be
mirroring because it's orthonormal right
it's just going to be some kind of
rotation right and then
step two is your multiplying it by a
diagonal matrix
which means you're just scaling along
the axis that's what a diagonal matrix
multiplying by diagonal matrix does
right take any vector
multiplied by a diagonal matrix it then
you're taking each component
and scaling that component along the
corresponding axis
by the value of the the element in
in in the corresponding diagonal entry
right so this is just
scaling
now scaling that is scaling
along the axis along the ah
the x and y axis not the eigen
eigenvector but scaling along the
axis
right now the scaling for the
singular value decomposition is always
real valued right ah because
s is always going to be real valued for
svd
so this is real valued scaling
right but for the eigen value
decomposition some of your eigen values
may be complex
and scaling by a complex value
essentially means
there is some amount of rotation
involved right scaling by
a complex number means there could be
rotation
if eigen value is complex
right and then step three is another
rotation
here the step three is going to be
rotating it by u
so this is just rotation 1 and this is
rotation 2
right means your we rotate
in svd we rotate it
scale it along the diagonals
after rotating and then rotate it by a
different amount
corresponding to u whereas with singular
value decomposition
with eigenvalue decomposition first we
rotate it then scale it
but the scaling may you know if you have
complex eigen values the scaling may
ah involve some implicit rotation and
then we
rotate it by u which is basically the
inverse of the first step
inverse of step one
right
in eigen value decomposition first you
rotate it by u inverse
then scale it and then undo the rotation
that was done by yes questions
so uh the so i would say
ignore this case for now um uh this is
this is uh
not very crucial for us i'm happy to go
deeper into that
after the lecture but essentially what
you want to think of this
you give some shape as input you know
you can characterize what a matrix a is
doing by
thinking of it as first rotating it by
some amount
and then scale the rotated version by
different amounts along
you know the x and y axis and then
rotate it by a different amount
right and it could be it is it is uh
different for svd in the sense it could
be you know
arbitrarily different but for the eigen
value decomposition you are going to
just undo the initial rotation
right and what you what you
what you see is that the the direction
that ends up aligning with the axes
after the first rotation are the
directions of your eigenvectors
right because you're gonna you're gonna
scale those
scale the points along the points along
the eigenvectors
after rotation will end up aligning with
the x axis
and when you scale them along the axis
these points
are not changing their direction once
you undo the rotation
does that make sense
so ah
what this means again in is that ah for
square matrices um
especially square symmetric matrices
where we don't care about complex eigen
values
for all square symmetric matrices we are
we
we're going to rotate the the action of
a can be summarized at
as rotated such that the eigen vectors
align with the axis
scale it by different amounts the
scaling could be negative which means
you're kind of mirroring it
and then undo the rotation you did in
the first step
right which means the the eigenvectors
and the axes of the
ellipsoid are going to be the same
right now for singular value
decomposition there are no eigenvectors
there are singular vectors uh but the
the
interpretation is is not not not as easy
because
um you're effectively rotating it by
some amount scaling it along the axis
and not undoing the rotation but just
rotating by a different you know
by u instead of v inverse
the the benefit of svd is that you
always get real singular values
but with eigenvalues you require the
matrix
to be square and symmetric to get real
eigenvalues but the singular values are
always real
and it so happens that if you are having
square symmetric matrices in your
eigenvalue
the singular value decomposition and
eigenvalue decomposition
will give you the same three components
so singular value decomposition and
eigen value decomposition are the same
for square symmetric matrices
for ah for a
arbitrary which means it need not be
square it need not be symmetric
right svd is the only thing that works
so svd is like a sledgehammer
throw any matrix at it it's going to
decompose it into three parts right
if a is square
you can still do svd but you can also do
an eigen value decomposition
some eigen values may be complex but if
you do an svd on a square matrix which
is not symmetric you still get
you know real valued singular values
and when a is square
and symmetric
then svd and eigenvalue decomposition
are the same
you know you get the same u
will be the same s and d will be the
same v transpose and universe will be
the same
yes
so when a square you can perform both
the eigenvalue decomposition
and the singular value decomposition but
the decomposed components
may not be identical right but if a is
square and symmetric
and you can perform both the
decomposition and the components will
also be the same so
svd and eigenvalue decomposition are you
know
it's the same decomposition if it's
square symmetric
it does not even exist i mean it's not
even defined so eigen value
decomposition is
defined only for square matrices so
eigenvalue you know algebraically
um the eigenvalue eigenvector is
basically the solution to
ax equals lambda x
right what it means is take a matrix a
multiplied by a vector x
and you're going to get an output vector
which is
you know along the direction of x but
scaled by some eigen value
right and all the solutions of this are
your eigenvalues and eigenvectors
right and in order for this to hold true
a has to be square
right for for this for this to be for
the output to be a scalar
a scaled version of the input a has to
be square otherwise it's just going to
be a
different dimension so uh eigen value
decomposition holds only for square
matrices
right
okay next we're going to move on to
matrix calculus any any questions about
this
yes question
yeah um for for uh it's it's you know
what
what you say is true in terms of in
terms of the intuition
you know you probably want to have this
as you know in in your mind in
for in terms of having the right
intuitions yes some matrices are are
you know not diagonalizable uh but
for the most part we're going to be
dealing only with
symmetric matrices you know square
symmetric matrices and we're going to be
mostly dealing with
with you know quadratic forms you know
for any given
in which case you have a corresponding
symmetric matrices and in case of
you know symmetric matrices you can
always
you can always decompose a square
symmetric matrices matrix
so the question is how do we test uh
whether a given matrix is
you know uh belong to any one of those
categories because we just cannot test
you know feed in all the possible values
of x and and see it and
um that's a great question and the
answer is we saw a one-to-one
correspondence between the
definitiveness
and the spectrum which means you can
always calculate the spectrum of a
matrix by doing an eigen decomposition
we haven't
discussed how you actually do this
decomposition right
and and we will we will probably see
that later in the course how you can
decompose it but there are lots of
methods to decompose a given matrix
into its you know eigenvalue
decomposition or singular value
decomposition
and then you can just inspect the
eigenvalues are they all positive are
they all negative and you know you get
the corresponding definitely
[Music]
so the question is can we swap
these two rows and columns and also the
corresponding you know diagonals and
also the corresponding rows yes you can
do that
but as a convention you just write them
in in descending order it's just a
convention
ok so moving on to matrix calculus
i should have probably swapped
so
all right so matrix calculus
let's see i'm assuming all of you are
familiar with with calculus
you know with the concept of
differentiation
and as a prerequisite you should have
already seen
multivariate calculus in terms of you
know
differentiating say a scalar valued
function that has a vector valued input
and such so in fact
everything that i'm covering today
you know hopefully this is not your
introduction to these subjects hopefully
you
you should have already seen them and
this should be like a refresher or you
know
just just to um you know recollect
things if you if you've forgotten them
so uh i'll i'll be skipping over a lot
of
um i'll be skipping over a lot of
precise rigorous statements and just
giving you the intuition so that you
know
you just remember things that you've
already studied so hopefully this is not
an introduction to these subjects for
you
right so uh
matrix calculus
calculus
right let's see let's look at a few
functions
right so we write a function
right
is this notation familiar to everyone
what this means is
we have a function that we're going to
call as
x as f f is the name that we assign and
this is like the type signature of that
function
it takes as input a real valued number
and produces as
output a real valued number
right now ah
an example this is you know x square
take a number x that is going to be the
input you square it
that is going to be the output right
real one you input real value output
and the
the value of this function
is real value
right this is just an example the
the first derivative of this function
is going to have a value in also in
r right and the second derivative
is going to have a value also in r so if
you have a function that takes a real
value input real valued output for
example
x square its value is is real value
right
its first derivative in this case 2x is
also going to be real valued
its second derivative just 2
is also going to be real value
right now consider a function
f
what does this mean means it's a
function that we can call this as f
the input of the function is going to be
some vector a d dimensional vector
right and the output is going to be a
real valued number
right so vector input scalar output
and we are going to encounter a lot of
functions of this kind in this course
right and the most common one that we
are going to
encounter is what you call as a loss
function
right we haven't covered what the last
function is yet but you know this just
this just to give you a sense of what uh
what's the kind of things you're going
to be uh looking at
uh the last function is as a value
a scalar value right
and what's the first derivative of a
vector what's what's what's the type of
the first derivative
of a function like this gradient it's
called a gradient
and the gradient is going to be in r d
right and the second derivative
derivative of a function like this is
called the
question and the hessian is
and the hessian in this case not only is
it a square matrix
it is also guaranteed to be symmetric
right and symmetric matrices are also
written
um as s with just a single d because it
is implied that it is d along both the
dimensions because it is symmetric
right and
again further later in the course we are
also going to encounter
functions of this type from rd
to rp
and its vector input vector output and
and
of course the dimensions are different
it they could be the same but in general
the dimensions are different
can anybody think of functions like this
why you might use such functions in
machine learning
i mean it's totally fine if uh
bias so
a function that takes a d-dimensional
vector and
outputs a p dimensional vector
projections and and uh another uh
um a commonly used used
component are going to be like a neural
network layer you're gonna
you know um the way neural networks work
is you you you transform
one vector to another in in some way and
it's uh you know one layer of neural
network can can look like this it takes
a d dimensional vectors input and
produces some other dimensional vectors
as um
output and there's a question
yeah yeah classification you you feed an
image as input and
you know output of a vector of
probabilities yeah that's that's you
know
that totally falls into this category as
well that's a good answer
and so the output here is going to be in
rp
right and what is the first derivative
of this of this kind of
a function gonna look what's what's the
type of
it's called jacobian exactly and it's
going to be r of
d by p what is it p by d anyway one of
the two
it's called the jacobian
and that is why if if if some of you are
already familiar with neural networks
you're going to encounter jacobians a
lot in neural networks because you know
that's how you train them by evaluating
the jacobians and
the second derivative for this is going
to be some kind of
d by p by p some kind of uh you know
let's just call it a higher order tensor
not very interesting right so ah
we see right away that you know vectors
and matrices are going to show up when
you do multivariate calculus
right and
the tools that we saw above for example
eigenvalue decomposition
can be applied to hessians and
that's going to tell you a lot of
information about the nature of the
function
right ah for example if you if you take
the hessian of a function
and if the hessian of a function is
positive semi-definite at all input
points x
then it means the the function is kind
of bowl shaped it is convex
right if you take some function and if
you
calculates its hessian and if it is
negative
definite or negative semi definite then
it is kind of an inverted ball shape
right and if the hessian of a function
is indefinite which means it is neither
positive definite or
in a semi definite then it is
exactly it it has saddle points what
does the saddle point mean it means
along one axis
it it it is you know cup shaped
and along another axis it is its kind of
bowl shape its like the shape of
a saddle that you place on a horse it
goes down along one axis
and you know goes up on another axis
right so
the the the connection between
multivariable calculus
and linear algebra is are very deep and
and
you're going to we're going to be using
and analyzing hessians
of different loss functions to kind of
characterize
are they convex which means if they are
convex you know that is
good news it means the when you minimize
the loss function
you reach a unique global minimum
because it's you know
any bowl shaped function or you know
take any bowl there's always like a
unique
uh global minima whereas if if a
function is is not convex
or if it has you know saddle points then
you know optimization
is is is a little harder trying to
minimize the loss function is going to
be harder
right now some examples of ah how we
actually go about calculating
gradients for example if you have a
function x
the gradient of the function with
respect to x is written like this
this is the terminology that we
generally use the inverted
triangle is is denotes the gradient
symbol
and if you if you are writing your
homeworks in latex
then this you know to get the symbol in
latex you use
backslash nabla
and the
the the uh subscript for nabla indicates
what is the variable with respect to
which you're
taking the um gradient and you know for
gradients this is going to be vector
valued obviously
and the definition is just this
take the partial derivative
of f with respect to x 1
and evaluate it as x so i am going to
use a red x here
to indicate that this is the value that
we are feeding and this is the variable
with respect to which we are
differentiating
x d f
right this is just the definition of a
gradient which means take
every because this is a
vector valued you know you can also kind
of think of this as
x x 1
x 2 x v right
and this is just a short short notation
for for this
so the the function has multiple inputs
because you're feeding in a vector of
values
and the gray and its output is scalar
and the gradient is then defined as the
partial derivative of
f with respect to every input
evaluated at the the vector that you are
feeding in right and this collection of
partial derivatives is called the
gradient
right and the gradient also has an
interpretation which is
it is the it is the direction of
steepest ascent
what does that mean if you have a um
so let us assume this is x one and this
is actually you know
x two and this is
f of x and
a scalar valued vector input
input function is going to be some
surface along this
you know in in such a graph um and the
the i'm not good at drawing surfaces
but you know imagine there is some kind
of a surface here
and the height from any point up to that
surface is the value of that function
right it's it's it's similar to you know
f of x except now it's it it has you
know multiple ah
input dimensions now along the surface
um the surface is going to have some
kind of you know a shape
and the gradient of the function at this
input
tells you the direction in which you
want to move
to to increase the value of the function
the most
right if you want to um the
i'm just going to try to draw a surface
right imagine this is some kind of a
surface now if you are
at this point and you want to adjust
your input to a different value such
that
the function evaluates to a larger value
then you calculate the gradient at this
point it's going to give you some
direction because it's a vector it's
going to give
point you in some direction and if you
take a very small step
along the direction from and from this
new point if you evaluate the value of
the function it should
be it should be larger right it gives
you like the direction
in which you want to move your input
such that the output value goes up
and similarly you can also calculate the
the
gradient of a function that takes
as a matrix as input with respect to the
matrix
right it that this is just a
generalization of this
right and this is going to be again
a whole collection of of
partial derivatives
right so
even though this is kind of a is is two
dimensional
just pretend it's one long vector kind
of serialize it into one
long vector right calculate the partial
derivatives
and then reshape it back into you know
um
a matrix any question
yes yes f is a function that takes
a as input a matrix as input and
produces a scalar as output
in this case in this case we are looking
at f is a function where it takes a
vector as input and scalar is out
yes
yeah yeah exactly so you know a is going
to be some kind of you know
some kind of uh um no a
it's going to have a 1 1 a
1 you know and assuming it is m by n
you know a n 1 till a
m 1 to a m n right so
you're feeding you know these many
different inputs
to f the output is a scalar so take the
partial derivative of
the output of f with respect to a 1 1
and
you know and so on
any questions about this right
now um
so this was f from
r m by n to
[Music]
r right and over here
f was from r
what did i use d to r
right we could also look at
what is what is the hessian
where x is again so f is from
rd to r
now the hessian is going to look like
this
now instead of taking the first partial
derivative we are going to take you know
two partial derivatives which means its
going to be del
square f by del x1
del x2 of
x
del square by del
x d del x
d of f
x similarly
del square del um
x 1 x
d x d
del x d f of
right so so here we take the second
partial derivatives of
f with respect to every input yes
question
oh yeah you're right thank you
x 1 x 1 x 1 x d x d x d and this will be
square x x
d x 1 f
of x the reason i'm highlighting things
in red is
to tell you that by performing the
partial
the partial derivative or two times
partial derivatives you're going to end
up with a function
and that function is this function for
which you feed any arbitrary x as as the
input
right is this clear
cool and
a few examples so um
some a few few things that you're going
to be using you know very liberally
throughout
what is the partial derivative of what's
the gradient with respect to x
of b transpose x where b is some vector
some constant vector you take a dot
product with x
and we want to calculate the the this
this is
scalar valued v transpose x is a scalar
and we want to calculate the gradient of
b
transpose x with respect to x will be
some constant
b right and why is that we apply
this directly so by definition
this is
i'm just going to write for some ith
element so partial
ah of x
i of b transpose x
right i have just applied this here
and this is going to be
x i of b 1 x 1 plus
b 2 x 2 plus b
d x d
right and when you when when you
calculate the partial derivative with
respect to
this all the terms except b i x i are
going to
cancel out because the rest of them are
all constants with respect to i
so maybe let us call this b i
i x i
right and this is going to give you
b i in this just b
right is this clear
the the the uh the
the function is simple but the
methodology is the same for any any
arbitrarily complex function
where we the gradient is just defined as
the collection of partial
derivatives with respect to every input
and then you
expand out the function calculate the
partial derivative with respect to the
corresponding input
and and then you finally see you know is
this a pattern that we recognize and in
this case it happens to be just b
otherwise your your gradient is just
some expression where
in general it need not have you know a
simple expression like this
right and so that's
that's how we calculate gradients for
simple functions
and similarly you can also apply um
just like regular calculus you can apply
the product rule
and we are going to see just one example
of the product rule so what is the
gradient with respect to x of x
transpose ax
right we're going to apply the product
rule as we know it
so this is going to be the gradient with
respect to
um i'm going to use two colors to
to
or precisely
i treat it as a product of two things
and
you know ah apply them ah differently
and this is going to
come out to be um so here the the
gradient here is um
you can think of this as gradient of
x with
so i forgot the transpose here
right so yeah so this is going to be
just ax
b transpose
ax and this is going to be a transpose x
right so ah the this is going to be
x times a plus a transpose and if
a is is a symmetric this is going to be
just
2ax
a few more
matrix derivatives which are going to be
very useful
i'm sorry what's that what's the
question
oh this is the product rule so for
example um um
when you are taking um
so d
by d x of f of
x g of x is equal to
d by d x of f of x
times g of x plus
f of x times d by
dx of g of x
it does the product rule and this is the
multivariate version of that
you think of this as f of x and g of x
exactly exactly exactly you know because
this is when when i write it as you know
uh
the gradient it's not clear to which
parts i'm applying it to
right so the red parts are the parts
that are getting differentiated the
black parts
you treat them as constants you know
just like this
i'm sorry
you could you could do that too but you
know generally you
yeah you could do that too yeah you
could
yeah you could you could right
so that's uh you know this is the
product rule
um another uh very useful
um identity that you're going to be
using
is going to be
gradient of a of the log of
the determinant of a
this looks pretty pretty nasty so what's
happening here a is a matrix
take the determinant of the matrix and
then you take the log of the determinant
of the matrix and you want to
differentiate it with respect to a
why would you want to do that i mean uh
but it it turns out that this
is going to be a recurring
a pattern this is going to show up in
multiple places
um especially when you are you're
dealing with you know gaussian
distributions and stuff you remember the
gaussian has a determinant in in
in the denominator anyways but this is
going to be
uh it's going to show up many times
in your homeworks possibly in your exams
um and the
the um the answer is just a inverse
right and the intuition is you know
d by dt of
rd by dx of log x is
x inverse it's it's you know think of it
like that
all right uh we have another 20 minutes
remaining
um let's see i'm going to do a quick
review of
probability in the meantime uh do you
have any other questions
yes question
the first time above it uh-huh
well i mean do you agree with this
i mean so this is this is just the same
thing in a multivariate setting
um
it is pretty straightforward it's in the
in the in the lecture notes i mean
in the review notes that's posted online
you can go through the steps
all right so this we're going to switch
gears now and
um briefly review probability theory
um that was it about in terms of
um review of matrix calculus and linear
algebra
um so we're going to switch guests to
probability theory now and this is going
to be the last
um last topic that we're going to review
and from next class we're going to you
know
start machine learning and you know with
linear regression
all right again um
treat this as a review and not as your
introduction to the subject
we are not going to teach it in the way
it has to be taught to a student the
first time we're just going to
review things so that it refreshes your
memory
okay so first of all what are the basic
elements of
probability theory right so in
probability theory there is
uh probability is is basically the study
of uncertainty about
um things that can happen randomly right
and
whenever we are talking about
probability there is always
an implicit sample space so sample space
r is is basically the set of all
all outcomes that can happen random
outcomes that can happen
right for example if we uh
your sample space can be what
what what what is the sequence of
coin tosses you get if you if you flip
it twice right is it going to be heads
heads or it's going to be heads tails is
it going to be
tail heads tail sales right now if if
the
experiment that you're performing is two
coin tosses
then any of these is a possible outcome
right and the set of all possible
outcomes
are called ah are are
is basically called the sample space
right
now ah the thing that
we assign probabilities to are called
events
right an event is a subset
of the sample space right
ah you want to think of um
let's see an event is is a subset of of
um
the uh sample space and in this case you
know
for example if a is is is some some
event ah
where it it includes you know heads
heads and heads tails
uh basically we are saying we are
interested in the event that
the first coin toss turns out to be a
heads right and
the full the entire probability the
sample space is also an event which
means we are interested in
you know anything that happens so it's
not very interesting
right so that's that's the event space
the set of all
possible subsets of your sample space
and now if your sample spaces is finite
the the event space is basically the
power set which means the set of all
subsets
is is the event space and then we assign
something called as a probability
measure
now the probability measure takes as
input an event not an outcome
an event and assigns it a value between
zero and one
right that's that's that's something you
want to keep in mind that we don't
assign probabilities to outcomes but we
actually assign probabilities to
events in the case of finite
finite sample space the distinction is
is moot
because you can always create a subset
that has only one
um that has only one event and assign a
probability that subset
but when we you know move on to uh
continuous spaced
uh continuous valued samples then you
know the distinction became becomes
more relevant now the
the the three main axioms or the three
axioms of probability are
that the probability assigned to an
event
is always greater than equal to zero for
all events
again the we are not talking about
outcomes we are talking about events
events are are sets of outcomes or you
know subset of
of the sample space the probability
assigned
to the entire event space or
or the entire sample space is always one
which means
some event or the other ins from the
sample space
will always occur right
and if you take disjoint events where
the the intersection between any two
events
are is the null set then the
probability assigned to the union of the
of of those disjoint
events is equal to just the sum of the
individual probabilities right
all very intuitive there's there's
nothing uh fancy happening here
then uh conditional probability um let
b be an event such that the probability
of b is not zero again
b is an event not an outcome which means
that we're talking about sets of
outcomes and probability of a given b
is is this is just the definition it's
the
probability assigned to the intersection
of a and b ah so the intersection
of a and b is also a set
and therefore also an event ah so it is
the event of
a intersection b divided by the
probability of ah
the event of b now ah
a and b are independent so the inverted
t symbol means
independent if the probability of a
intersection b
is the same as the probability of a
times the probability of b
right and to to i mean this should this
should make sense right a
intersection b is always going to be a
subset of a or subset of b
and probability of a and probability of
b are you know values between zero and
ones and when you multiply two
numbers that are you know smaller than
the one then you're going to get a value
which is you know even
even smaller
again uh probability of a and b are
independent events if and only if
probability of
a given b is is
equal to the probability of a which
means the probability of a
does not change whether b occurred or
not
right so you you then a and b are
independent
now random variables now consider
um um an event where you know the
experiment is
say 10 10 coin tosses and you know this
is one such event
now a random variable is a function that
maps
outcomes to real values now we are not
talking about events we are talking
about outcomes
you know the the the um the atoms of of
of
what happens in in a random as a random
occurrence
right a random variable is a mapping
from
outcomes to real values
this is just an example of a random
variable here where given an outcome
you know that sequence of heads and
tails the function
just counts the number of heads in it
you know that's that's just a function
and you know the output is is a real
value
so it it's kind of useful to uh think
about it like this um i'm gonna i'm
gonna
i'm gonna call this the
the uh outcome space
and this
to be the real line right now
the outcome space has you know lots of
different
actual outcomes and then
on top of these outcomes we define
events
right and events could be overlapping
right and a random variable is a
function that maps
outcomes to real values
and here this is you know this is a
straight line which which means to say
you know it's
you know this is just the real line and
i intentionally draw the outcome space
with a wiggly line because
this is just a bag of things that happen
there is no natural order among these
right so if you if you take a die ah
which is color for example without the
numbers one to three on it and you roll
the die
some color is going to show up right and
you can think of those as the different
outcomes where colors are not
order but then you can define a random
variable
which maps each side of the die to a
number for example you you number them
one two three you know that's
essentially your defining a random
variable
where you are now mapping the random
events to the real line
right so you know this could be a random
variable
a random variable is a function you know
it's a very poorly chosen name
a random variable is neither random
neither is it a variable it's just a
function
it's a function that maps outcomes to
real values
i mean it's it's it's just like computer
science it's just a horrible name it's
not about computers it's not a science
but you still call it computer science
right so um a random variable is neither
random nor
is it a variable it's just a function
that maps
outcomes to to the real line
right however we assign probabilities
to events right we don't assign
probabilities to outcomes that we
assign probabilities to events and the
reason why we
we kind of interested in random
random variables is because ah by
defining a random variable
we are now kind of bringing
any experiment into a level playing
field you know you map them into the
real line
and you start the rest of your analysis
starting with the real line
right you're kind of abstracting away
what the specific details of
the random event are just map them all
to the real line and now
you know you can you can have like a
unified theory of what you can
you know do with you know random things
happening on the real line
right so by a value of x we mean you
know the set of all values that
x can x can take so in this case you
know
this random variable can take any of
these values
and if it is a discrete random variable
then your function will look like this
each thing gets mapped to a different
number
each outcome gets mapped to a different
right and this is going to be a discrete
random variable
right and the val val x of
that would be you know the different
values the random value
the random variable can take
right and then we have something called
the cumulative distribution function
now the the as i said earlier
probabilities are defined on
events and that probability is being
defined
in this space onto events now the
cumulative distribution function
is trying to map you know these
probabilities to probabilities along
along the real value right the
definition of
the cdf is fx of
x is equal to the probability that
x is less than x and what this
actually means is you know what what
what does actually mean
it means the probability assigned to
the set of all outcomes omega
such that x of
omega is less than maybe
let me call this t just less than
t right what does it mean so
look at your random variable there is
some
choose a t and get the set of all
omegas such that x of t x x of
omega is less than t right so in this
case it is this one
this one this one and
create a set out of those
ah create a set out of create an event
out of those outcomes
and measure the probability on that
event
because we always measure probability in
in in the sample space
or the event space right and
we pretend that the cdf is measuring
probabilities on the real line but
actually what it does is
we map it back find the image pre image
corresponding to
corresponding to the the set we are
interested and
measure the probability in the in the
event space
right and the cdf looks like this um
a cdf looks like this because uh
the the picture that we that we see is
is you know
you know you gotta flip it over you know
here we are mapping from
the the uh uh outcomes to the real line
but over here you know
um once we are once we are kind of
comfortable with this agreement
you know moving forward we start with a
real line as
as as our basis and define probabilities
there
yeah so omega is the sequence
of heads tails you know the long
sequence is
omega it's just a string of heads tails
whatever
and then given that as an input you can
count the number of heads in it
and the function that takes the string
as input and returns
the number as output is is the random
variable
right and then you have discrete versus
continuous random variables
we went through this again already
i'm just going to skip over these
and ah the the way we uh uh calculate
the the so so the the cdf is defined
this way right
and the cdf is essentially gives you
you know uh it it it kind of decouples
you from
the event space and allows you to only
think about
you know the the real line and once we
define a random variable
you know we we forget what the event
space was what the outcome space was and
and only deal with the real line and so
the um
the cdf tells you what is the
probability
that the that your random variable
is less than or equal to some value t
and the height of the cdf
is gives you that that value
and the cdf is always between zero and
one
right the the at minus infinity
the cdf is zero at plus infinity the cdf
reaches 1.
and the probability mass function is
is defined for discrete random variables
where there is a probability assigned to
an to a given number so a probability
mass function would
would look like this this is r then
at 0 you have some height where the
height describes
the probability assigned right and again
all of these will be between 0 and
0 and 1 and the sum of all these heights
should add up to 1
right that's a probably mass function
similarly if it's a
continuous value then you have a
probability
density function
and the probability density function is
basically the derivative of
the probability cumulative
cumulative density function or the cdf
expected value so this is probably uh
the most
important concept that we're going to
encounter and
i'm just going to finish expectation and
then we can break for the day
so what's the expected value the
definition of expected value
is like this so let g be a function
from r to
[Music]
r which means let's assume g
you know this is some function g
this is r and this is r
and the expectation of g
of x now if the input that we feed to g
is a random variable which means the
the actual event that can get fed is
is random ah that get fed as input as
random then the
expectation of g of x is defined like
this
for you know the sum over every possible
um x that can be fed as input
evaluate g at for that input multiplied
by the probability
that that x can get fed according to the
random variable
and if x is continuous then it is the
integral
now one way to think of it is like this
if this defines if
if your x that you are feeding to g
is random then your g of x
your x has some kind of a probability
density
right so this is this is x
this is the pdf of x
the probability density function and
this is g of x
right now what the expectation is is
telling you
is if you were to sample your x's
according to
this density if you randomly sample x is
according to this density
and then for each of those samples
evaluate
g of x
and then kind of average them
you know and take the average over here
it's going to be some
some value and this is expectation of
g of x which means if you're if you're
sampling
x's according to the random variable x
evaluating
g on those sample inputs
what is the average value of g you would
get if you were to repeat this
experiment
you know indefinitely long right what's
the expected value
of the output of g if your inputs
are sampled according to x so that's
that's um
the expectation of g of x and this
procedure of calculating the
expectation so the analytical definition
is here that's the integral of g of x
f of x dx the
the other interpretation of this is to
um take the average
1 over n g of
some over i equals 1 2 and g of
x i where x i are random samples
that you that you of random samples of
x that is the input drawn according to
the density
right evaluate it at g of x and take the
average
right and what we basically know is that
the limit of this
as n tends to infinity which means
if if you perform this procedure with
larger and larger number of samples
the limit of this tends to the integral
of
infinity g of x and
p of x dx where p of x is the
probability density g of x
is the function that we are trying to
calculate expectation over
and this this statement is also called
the
anybody
this is called the law of large numbers
large numbers right super important
and this estimate of the expectation
you know ah so this is this is an
approximate estimate of the expectation
which the where the the approximation
gets better and better as you increase
the number of n
and this estimate is also called the
anybody
it is called the monte carlo estimate
right i am sorry
monte carlo estimate right this is the
monte carlo estimate
and as you as you increase n to infinity
your monte carlo estimate becomes the
true
expectation and that's that's basically
a consequence of the
law of large numbers and we're going to
be seeing
the monte carlo estimates for various
you know for various
purposes in machine learning and in this
course as well